what is up there reject nation greg and
john here today we're gonna watch star
wars visions episode three we just
watched the first two reactions should
be up for those but guys if you end up
enjoying our reaction hit that like
button helps us on the algorithm also
subscribe and click the notification
bell yeah as always full length watch
long for your sync up with the time code
over at our patreon page over there we
have the option for reaction highlights
and watch alongs included at the same
tier for many shows pritham jindal
thanks for editing these down for us i
know it's your pleasure
[Music]
whoa there's an outline there the stars
destroyer
ah
i was right
you nailed it
oh
is that our homie
cool
[Music]
got a bit of a different strut to his
walker swagger got some shoulders
shoulder action stretch your stuff
oh i like the sci-fi
cyberpunk anime five that it's already
breaking
master app we have completed all of the
final adjustments on the gemini class
star destroyer we are ready to deploy
and are awaiting your command
ever since you and your brother were
delivered to our care i have watched you
grow and now i will finally be able to
witness you complete your mission
it has been quite the journey
with this new power my brother and i
will bring order to the galaxy
this is our mission as twins created
through the power
oh damn nice will the weapon's firepower
be at full strength
she looks like a xenomorph
high purity energy must be extracted
from our power source in the central
core it is the same power that is
transferred into the dark armor that you
and your brother master kareem
power source from the reactor core
appears to have been stolen we cannot
charge the hyper cannon
but only master and master kari can
access the reactor core tinker
what are you doing brother
so that was invader
look like it
please return the power cord this is
your last warning
[Music]
[Music]
lucy's nice about it the ship is right
where we left it
god not where i left you
where were you planning on going with
that
to a galaxy far far away
now hand it over
oh
i refuse
[Music]
if you won't hand it over then i'll take
it
nope
[Music]
holy moly
oh
that's right wow
[Music]
what a bad asteroid
great now get ready to punch it
it's like an embodiment of anakin and
han yeah
really so you have a bad feeling about
this
you're wrong it's not tractor beam it's
ass she's a sucker
there she's strong oh badass
[Music]
she's going for the power core
absolutely
she's gonna rip your ship apart to take
it
oh no
[Music]
no
such beauty
such power
oh
now come
i won't let you have it only thing that
this crystal can possibly bring is
despair
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh she pissed
[Music]
if you use the power of the kyber
crystal
then you will i will die
surely that cannot be the reason you
stole it to save me
yes that's correct
however even if i had told you about
this he would have never listened to me
regardless i wasn't about to just let
you die and so that's why i
said nph do you think i fear death no
don't
oh
i will make death yield to me and i'll
do it with the power of the dark side
[Music]
herself
[Music]
oh
what do i do
i don't know
i can use this absolutely
try on a new color blade
wow
[Music]
look at that color gradient on the blade
wow you're just showing off lady
oh cool
[Music]
oh
my man
can no longer control it and now her
armor is overloading
if we don't destroy that thing as
quickly as possible it will kill her
however it would take a massive amount
of power to do that
what if i'm not strong enough to save
her what do i do mustn't doubt yourself
the hyperdrive
if i use the power of the ship's
propulsion system then it just might
and my lightsaber i'm just not sure if
i'll be able to try something so
reckless
you got no choice man you got this
[Music]
just like you say
there is no try only do i can make this
work
god the perspectives in this episode i
just have a yoda shirt that said that
[Music]
holy wow
nice
i love it
this crystal is destroyed then our
entire life's mission will be lost
destiny
[Music]
wow okay about slicing in half
now wow
that's beautiful
like twin destroyers and
i just took a star destroyer and
scrunched them together
she's out there
she's alive i can feel it
after all
she is my twin sister
[Music]
that's how being twins works like luke
and han combine
i was originally saying
originally saying like
anakin because i was like oh from the
darks
alice and brie but then
he was just straight up a good guy
he was like
is there any vestiges of the sin
i was like you're a little too good you
know that's an insane backstory but it
doesn't seem like any of this
is no darkness how long have you been
planning this turn
when did you change
uh yeah but that was still visually
beautiful yes all fronts man that was
awesome neil patrick harris
allison bree ooh i love allison bree
you're good she's a good animation voice
actress it was really cool to like
have this all be visually realized like
it's i don't know what the hell you call
this ship was it a twin destroyer
oh they they said it was like a a gemini
class star destroyer or something like
that they literally took two to star
destroyers and tied them together and
put a big gun in the middle yeah because
we got to represent the
we gotta represent the twins yeah we
need ships that really represents
his and hers twin ship but the designers
are clearly aping off of like the star
destroyer you know and then the empire
that's the whole point of what you're
looking at inside so seeing that
anime visually realized was cool i mean
when he first showed up kari i thought
that was i thought that was vader i just
thought it was the anime take on peter
yeah yeah
you know
i was like oh cool this is definitely
vader one art duo as a name even throws
you off a little bit yeah exactly
and of course the climactic fight
towards the end and i love the idea too
of like the kyber crystals how she like
embodies them like what they did with
more than just a lightsaber duel because
it's like when you first saw her in the
trailer i thought it was gonna be like a
general grievous sort of fight where you
have like multiple arms and fighting
because it's they both embody the kyber
crystal they extend in in like very
unique ways that make the animation very
sweeping like hers move like whips and
he's got like this
crazy light beaming sword
keeps changing the different it has like
a glass this energy connection flow
thing
going on it runs the color spectrum i
mean they're like when it's the most
solid it's like you know red towards the
bottom and blue towards the top yeah and
then there's one point where it fluxes
through like green and yellow and purple
and all sorts of other things yeah the
infinity stones yeah
did the lightning it was red right yeah
is that the first time we've seen red
lightning yeah cause isn't pallops isn't
his still just lightning colored
because i don't know at least in the in
the live action because also too like
you know the rise of skywalker when ray
does yeah lightning blast i feel like
part of that is like the visual cue is
like oh dang is that some sith stuff
yeah yeah you know so yeah i i
in my
incredibly knowledgeable on the star
wars canon opinion this is probably
one of uh a few if not the first
appearance of red lightning well it kind
of had me thinking of like this is the
children of vader and a different path
they went down i thought it was gonna be
that this was the sith version of luke
and leia that's essentially what i think
they were going for yeah their twin
brother and sister yeah and even
literally like luke and han combined
yeah you know yeah
his whole personality even his look
he's got like the hair in the face of
luke and the clothes
yeah
you know so that's where my mind went
with his character and she doesn't
really remind me of layout or the fact
that he's a twin sister
no because because she would just be a
totally different person if she was a
in fact she reminds me more of the
villain from jedi fallen order which i
feel like an astronaut remembering her
name right away she was a really
compelling character though it's a good
game by the way guys you should play it
if you haven't played it to me it's like
the big takeaway it's just a fight scene
on top of there the first episode seems
like it had a it was there was a big
fight but it seemed like it was more
about the aura and the story and the
second one is like fun and this one was
like the big epic star wars space battle
well it's like the the space battle and
how expression it we could be with
everything you know from the debris to
the way the the uh we talked about with
the way the light works with the kyber
crystals and all the variety of the
weapons just the sweeping shots that you
have here like i love that shot where
he is on top of his x-wing i think
x-wing is outside of the x-week and then
uh they're going into the destroyer he's
like cut slicing it in half with the
kyber crystal you know and how it's like
specifically targeting the kyber crystal
within his sister's chest plate i love
the way how all that was visually
realized like
to me i'm like just that fight alone is
worth recommending this episode because
of how great it is and all the
flourishes like with at first when they
lock powers and there's that jittering
debris that then grows into just this
orbital and ever shifting pattern of
space junk as they fight in the middle
of it and yeah then like they made so
much out of the tone and out of just the
elements of the atmosphere and you know
the elements literally of the star wars
universe with yeah these different
beams of light and kyber crystal effects
and whatnot a very physical episode
uh i think i would have been a lot more
touched by the characters though if i
did feel there was a little bit more
darkness towards the main guy i gotta
admit like i didn't fully buy
the voice work for neopet that for cars
i was thinking
because i really bought am
quite a bit yeah
but i was really much i was very much
aware of voice over
when it came to the car a character yeah
i was really aware that i was like this
really sounds like i should be watching
the japanese version but i didn't really
feel that way i didn't really feel that
way when i was watching anne but that
could have something to do with the
writing of the character because the
character just sounds so such a neil
patrick harris's voice just sounds like
such a good person so uplifting always
striving for hope there's not much
gravitas in the voice of neil patrick
harris you would think there would be uh
with a character who was literally bored
into darkness born to be a sith you
would imagine some dark but he just felt
so light-hearted yeah like so good you
know and like not really any conflict on
the choice at hand here of like you're
betraying someone who you really care
about it's like i mean he says like i
don't care about you know any of it but
i'm like but you still seem like a good
person
seemed like so good but you know i feel
like that point's already been made on
our end about that character because
still though it didn't take away my uh
enjoyment of the episode and i wonder
how that would play in the in the and
the japanese version that's a big
question i'm that's really in my mind
right now
is it will that be very different in the
japanese version because that is a
missing quality to me here it's hard for
me to feel the history with these two
who are brother and sister born into
this one performance is so drastically
different and doesn't hint at all
towards like
having a conflict or a pain
yeah of like oh yeah you could tell this
guy's had like i felt like there was
more fascinating mystery and history to
the character in the first episode who
you learn like nothing about you know
but you learn what you need to where
it's
yeah here it's just kind of like how did
you wind up like luke skywalker yeah
what what inspired this turn in you how
long did you have to live as this sort
of double agent how did you manage not
to let anybody know about your turn up
until this point it's like i don't even
know the text of that i just need to
feel it to a certain extent you know it
needs to be evident yeah he just seemed
too good to me yeah he seemed like he
was always a good guy he burned this
woman like
i don't know i feel like you could have
maybe added just a little more story
grit because they also have that time
travel element of like he's in
some kind of outside this main time
moment with the past version of am
basically showing her what she's to
become yeah i don't know if that was him
accessing the veil of the force or not
and it still was like a unique power it
was i mean it's cool
yeah it's just like i thought that they
bothered to do that and that was like a
really interesting moment i thought they
could have maybe built on that to
perhaps show us a little bit more of
their past to make their present more
interesting because when we meet them
it's like he's this total badass this
total vader looking guy where i'm like
you've got a full-on special outfit you
must have done some dastardly deeds to
get here yeah yeah you know you must
have been a bit evil or had to turn a
blind eye to some evil in order to get
to this point none of that grizzled uh
you know heroin that does something to a
person with a conscience you know and
that's not very evident yeah i just hate
neil patrick harris i just hate him i've
never liked him in anything that's why i
don't want to see the new matrix that's
why i only watched every episode of how
i met your mother with barney's scenes
yeah i had a friend do a special fan
edit for me
and
scenes where i wouldn't play without him
we just replaced him with another ted
always skip over him and harold and
kumar and his dramatic work too even in
in movies like gone girl i just
skip it and skip those scenes even no
matter how pivotal they are and
important to the story i think neil
patrick harris is a great actor right i
really i just wonder if there was just a
missing direction on the character and
the voice booth that's all that's what
i'm saying yeah absolutely i don't want
this to overshadow the enjoyment of the
episode though i really don't want it to
be the case because we spend so much
time and i feel like we've already made
the point of gazillion times yeah yeah
so yeah we should just drop it it's not
bad he's a fine performance that could
have had more dimension all right guys
so what'd you think about this episode i
thought it was gorgeous to behold and uh
be cool to unpack these characters more
in some type of expanded thing even if
it was like a video game or comic or
something it'd be cool to really unpack
these guys
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button a few more episodes to go but so
far so good i would rank it so far one
three two absolutely i am with you
everett baker everett you've been part
of our patreon page for a couple months
now we still haven't talked to each
other that's mainly my fault i'm so
sorry i'm just not doing enough and i'm
trying to do more but i'm still not
doing enough that's my secret cap i
never do enough
and what i wanted to say though is like
we were going through our patreon list
of who to shout out you seem like the
one who would be most identifiable the
identifiable
who would identify most of the main
character here because your name looked
it up means wild boar
yeah that means that too but it also
means hard brave hearty strong
that is so representative of this
character here if there's someone here
who
it seems like they're destined to help
us fight in this world it's got to be
the wild boar over at our patreon page
that's what you are to us ever oh my god
that could be your wrestling name
everett the wild boar
baker
yeah we gotta change your last name
doesn't really work with the baker at
the end
makes it a little too soft
soft
killer crusher yeah man toaster but
either way thank you for being part of
our patreon page because really that
could be the bravest thing you can do
most people who pledge go not worth my
time and money but you found a way to
make it worth your time and money i
think or maybe you just forgot to
unpledge after you realize it was a
waste of your time and money
power move but i feel like we have made
this worth your time and money with this
excellent appreciative shout out
[Music]
you